Kennt ihr diese momente auf reisen in denen man einfach innehalten muss weil man das was man, sieht einfach viel
zu krass findet egal ob gigantische wasserfälle bedrohliche lavafelder oder bizarre felsformationen
Unsere erde ist wirklich voll mit
einzigartigen und magischen naturwundern wie der grösste meteoritenkrater der welt aussieht wo genau der
hitzepol der erde liegt und noch viele weitere absolut spektakuläre orte dieser welt jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Der countdown beginnt platz 6 der hitzepol der erde wir befinden uns in der ludwig sste
Im iran hier befindet sich der hitzepol der erde und zwar mit rund
70 grad celsius
Im jahr 2005 wurde hier mit einem infrarot radiometer das satelliten aqua die
Bodentemperatur ermittelt und ihr könnt es euch vorstellen hier ist es wirklich
unvorstellbar heiß und das macht diesen ort zu einem eher
lebensfeindlichen raum doch
forschungsteams haben hier tatsächlich leben gefunden
skorpione zb die sich an die extremen verhältnisse angepasst haben sie ernähren sich vom tod genauer genommen von
verirrten
Zugvögeln die in der heißen wüstenluft sterben und einfach vom himmel fallen doch trotzdem hat dieser ort irgendwie etwas
unter anderem krasse felsformationen die haben dazu geführt dass die unesco die ludwig zum weltnaturerbe
Erklärt hat und auf der fünf die längste. Höhle der welt
590 kilometer lang und sehr weit verzweigt das sind die gigantischen ausmaße der männer skfm
Us bundesstaat kentucky das riesige, höhlensystem aber nicht plötzlich
So da sondern hat eine lange geschichte wohl ein paar millionen jahre lang haben wassertropfen das höhlensystem aus dem porösen kalkstein
herausgewaschen entstanden sind zum teil
Riesige säle mit stall aktiven und stalagmiten die mamas cave bildet das zentrum eines riesigen
naturschutzgebietes eine absolut magische welt in den höhlen selbst leben beispielsweise
grillen, fische und fledermäuse und auch als christ davon hinein und an touren teilnehmen
auf der 4 der größte meteoritenkrater der welt einen durchmesser von knapp
500 kilometern hat der wohl größte methoden krater der welt der
Wilkes lampater lange blieb er uns unter dem eis der östlichen antarktis verborgen noch immer nicht
Zu 100 prozent geklärt ist wie wilkes land entstanden ist doch es spricht einiges dafür dass wohl ein
Meteorit dafür gesorgt hat forschungsteams schätzen die größe dieses methoden auf rund 50 kilometer zeitpunkt
des geschehens war übrigens vor etwa 200 50 millionen jahren
Im jahr 2006 zeigt ein forschungsteam auf der fachkonferenz der american geophysical union in baltimore
erstmals darstellung zudem will chris landkarte
spekuliert wird auch dass der gewaltige
meteoriteneinschlag vor
250 millionen jahren wohl zu einem der größten massensterben der erde geführt hat und zudem auch zur entstehung
des
australischen kontinents platz 3 der tiefste canyon der welt hier guckt man auch besser nicht nach unten
auch wenn die genaue tiefe der schlucht caligari
Nepal unbekannt ist steht wohl fest dass sie die tiefste der welt ist man schätzt ihre tiefe von
6000 metern
Benannt wurde sie genau wie der fluss zu ihren füßen nach einer hinduistischen göttin die für die macht der naturkräfte steht wirklich
Passen um sie herum gibt es majestätische berge mehr als
8000 meter hoch die ureinwohner
Halten diesen ort der erde für heilig die mutigsten bringen sammeln auf dem grund der schlucht die sogenannten salleck maren stein im wasser
Sie sind heilig und in indien sind sie mehr wert als gold entstanden sind sie sind sie aus
weichtieren die vor millionen jahren, im fluss lebten heute sind hier auch viele touristen unterwegs
Im besten fall immer mit einem guide der weg durch die schlucht
Dauert etwa zwei tage auf der zwei platz zwei die meisten gewitter. Im jahr das jahr hat 365
Tage an 15 bis 45 tagen davon etwa gibt es bei uns in deutschland im jahresdurchschnitt
Gewitter je nachdem in welcher region man sich befindet an den küsten blitzt und donnert es
Deutlich weniger als beispielsweise in der nähe der alten finde
Ich kann man aushalten vor allem wenn man sich vorstellt dass es in der gewitter hauptstadt der welt ganze
322 tage im jahr gewitter gibt andersherum gerechnet, also 43 tage pro jahr an denen es nicht blitzt und donnert
unvorstellbar wenn er also wissen wollen wohin ja auf gar keinen fall umziehen sollte merkt euch bongo in
indonesien ihren spitznamen trägt die stadt völlig zurecht kotaku an übersetzt regen statt hier ist es nur selten wärmer als
26 grad das in kombination mit dem vielen wasser und dem fruchtbaren
vulkanischen unten ist ein paradies für die pflanzenwelt und deswegen ist sogar weltweit nicht nur für seine vielen gewittern bekannt sondern auch für
seinen botanischen garten mehr als 6000 pflanzenarten darunter knapp 900 orchideen sorten gibt es hier
genauso wie viele fledermäuse und mehr als 50 verschiedene vogelarten und der platz eins der
Kälteste ort der erde wobei es sind mehrere ich habe mich gleich drei krasse locations erde für euch wo man sich besser nicht länger
Falsch gekleidet, im freien aufhalten sollte zu einem die russische forschungsstation wostok in der antarktis die lange
Als kältepol der erde galt am 23 juli 1983 wurde hier eine temperatur von minus
89,2 grad celsius gemessen wenn hier polarer sommer herrscht gibt es auch mal milde minus 30 grad
Herrlich von hier aus sind es noch 1200 87 kilometer zum geografischen südpol hier hat ein forschungsteam einen ice kern gebohrt der
420.000 jahre klimageschichte
erzählt
2013 wurde der kälterekord von rostock allerdings überboten bzw besser gesagt
Unterboten satelliten messungen der nasa zeigen den kältepol der erde an einem eher drücken in der nähe von dome argus
einer hochebene der antarktis minus
93,2 grad celsius wurden hier am 10 august
2010 gemessen die kasse kälte entstand wodurch die große höhe über dem meeresspiegel gepaart mit einem wolkenfreien himmel
67,8 grad celsius - wurden übrigens in der sibirischen siedlung ya konan gemessen es ist der wohl kältesten
Dauerhaft bewohnte ort der welt und das krasse daran, im sommer können es in dieser region auch
Mal 30 grad und mehr werden ich selbst
Habe es mal in sibirien erlebt innerhalb von zwei wochen wurde es von -25 plus 40 grad das ist
kontinentales klima wenn ihr kein
Video verpassen wollt von clixoom zu den spektakulären themen aus der wissenschaft dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergessen dich den
Genau auf die glocke denn nur dann verpasst er keine videos wie
sensation interstellare objekt rast durchs sonnensystem
darauf klicken wenn ihr das sehen wollt das ist ab
sensationell und erstmalig also ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran